[Music]
on this wednesday night impatience
with rule breakers one province's
promise of hefty fines and tighter
restrictions
they're going to be the highest in the
country and the solution to long waits
for covid19 tests and results
as two federal political leaders go into
self-isolation
the impact on parliament hill crude
awakening the oil industry's gloomy
forecast and how companies are adapting
a slow-moving storm assaults the gulf
coast we're going to try survive
this the danger from hurricane sally
and from playing defense to defending a
man
wrongfully convicted she's such an
amazing beautiful person
a love story that blossomed during a
fight for freedom
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
if you're still not getting the message
about the risk of covid19 spreading
there are some clear signs tonight you
should pay attention to
ontario where daily case numbers are
rising in three regions including
toronto
the premier is getting ready to bring
the hammer down tighter limits on social
gatherings
and bigger fines are coming there's
going to be some severe severe fines for
people want to
ignore the regulations and the
guidelines so it's going to be severe
they're going to be the highest in the
country and they're going to be under
provincial jurisdiction it's not going
to be under
federal jurisdiction so we'll make sure
that they're followed through
the virus is still spreading the federal
opposition leader and the leader of the
bloc quebecois are now
self-isolating because people close to
them have tested positive
we'll have more on that in just a moment
first here's a snapshot of new cases in
canada today both ontario and quebec
recorded more than 300 new infections
their highest daily new case loads in
months out west there were 171 new cases
in alberta and 122
in bc a critical number to watch is how
many people need to be hospitalized
right now the number of covid19 patients
admitted to hospitals in the four
largest provinces
is far below the peaks in the spring but
in some regions the number of severely
ill people
is creeping up in ontario 44 people with
covid19 are in the hospital
20 of them are in intensive care in bc
60 people are in the hospital 23 in icu
with case numbers climbing the demand
for covid 19 tests
is skyrocketing in parts of this country
in places like toronto and
ottawa people are waiting in line for
hours outside testing centers
once they finally get the test it's then
taking days to get the results
jeff semple reports on the backlog and
what's being done
to fix it how do you feel about not
going to school today
tugba tasa's five-year-old woke up on
her first day of school
with a runny nose a possible symptom of
covid19
it's probably just a cold public health
set to get tested if you want her to
come back
but they arrived at their local testing
center to this
hundreds in line with reported wait
times at some ottawa centers of up to
eight
hours and i'm just glad today is a
really nice weather and we're outdoors
but i can't imagine going through this
in winter these long anxious lineups are
playing out across the country
particularly in ontario
as children head back to school their
parents to work
while others with no symptoms are
looking to socialize
safely i'm going up to see some people
so they wanted to test
feel more safe the result some patients
turned away
others waiting hours in line and up to
10 days
for results they could do it at home it
could be done in a fraction of the time
that the current test is being done in
this toronto dentistry professor says
there's a better way
covid19 tests which can be conducted at
home
using saliva instead of an uncomfortable
nasal swab
the sample then sent to a lab other
so-called rapid antigen tests can
produce results at home
in less than an hour including one being
developed in saskatchewan
it's like a pregnancy test that is
changed the color
when you are positive the saliva and
rapid testing technologies have already
been deployed
in several countries including the
united states but are still waiting for
approval from health authorities in
canada
in canada we're very careful and that's
fine but
we're in a pandemic situation in an
emailed written statement a spokesperson
for health canada
notes lingering concerns around the
reliability of some of those at home
covid19
tests adding that they are assessing all
applications as quickly as possible
without compromising patient safety in
the meantime
the ontario government is now planning
to partner with local pharmacies
in hopes of doubling its testing
capacity
donna all right jeff semple in toronto
thanks
the federal conservative leader erin
o'toole and his family is among those
getting tested for covid19 because one
of his staff has the virus
and the block quebecois leader eve
francois blaschette is in self-isolation
because
his wife has tested positive it is a
live issue right now at the heart of
parliament and with a throne speech
just a week away our ottawa bureau chief
mercedes stephenson is with me mercedes
what do we know about
o'toole and blanchette well donna it's a
reminder that there is no such thing as
being safe from potential covet 19
exposure
whether you are the prime minister or a
party leader the risk is now
top of mind as kovit 19 has arrived on
parliament hill
and there is an unprecedented
possibility of two
opposition leaders or numerous mps being
absent from a confidence vote
the speech from the throne is a critical
moment for any government
but especially in minority parliaments
the vote that follows can bring down a
government
it's unclear whether conservative leader
aaron o'toole or block leader e francois
blachette
or most of the block caucus for that
matter will be out of self-isolation in
time for the vote
o'toole and his family are in isolation
tonight after an o-tool staffer
traveling with the leader
tested positive o'toole's twitter
account showed this photo of him driving
back from montreal with staff earlier
this week
not wearing a mask the opposition
leader's office put out a press release
saying he would be tested on wednesday
but refused to confirm to global news
whether or not that test had happened
the leader's office is now reaching out
to everyone otool was in contact with in
recent days
including quebec premier francois lago
who says he is not being tested right
now on the advice of public health
officials
despite this face-to-face meeting with
no masks on monday
the concerns come just one day after a
guard in the parliamentary protective
service was diagnosed with covid19
triggering a review of the security
services coveted policies
donna as for the throne speech mps still
cannot vote electronically
despite having virtual question period
today prime minister justin trudeau
says he wants a hybrid house so that mps
can vote remotely
in this pandemic which is not going away
anytime soon
a majority vote by mps would be all
that's needed to change the rules
so they could vote from home mercedes
you and i have talked before about all
the rumors about a possible fall federal
election
where does that stand now donna it feels
like an appetite for an election is
dropping off amid the growing number of
kovit-19 cases
prime minister trudeau says he doesn't
want an election but he is confident
that elections canada could hold one
safely if it were to happen as for now
the government is focusing on getting
canadians through the pandemic
and that will be what is reflected in
the speech from the throne he says
donna all right mercedes stevenson in
ottawa thanks
south of the border there are reports
multiple staff at the white house have
tested positive for covet 19.
president trump confirmed today one
staff person is positive he gave no
other details however members of the
white house press pool say they were
told multiple staff members are positive
yesterday president trump hosted the
leaders of israel the uae and bahrain
for the signing
of a peace agreement canada's hard-hit
oil and gas sector will be watching the
prime minister's speech from the throne
closely next week
there have been repeated requests for
aid because of covid19 and a
big dip in global oil prices now opec
says the economic hit from the pandemic
will hurt global energy demand
harder and for longer than previously
feared
though alberta's premier disputes any
interpretation that the outlook for oil
is gloomy eric sorenson explains
climate change has been front and center
this week a new report on a warmer
climate in the north
a water-laden hurricane in the south and
heat wave-induced wildfires
in the west the changing climate and an
economy ravaged by covet 19
has prompted a stark forecast from a
major oil producer
bp says the growth of global oil
consumption is coming to an end
and will peak in the next few years if
it hasn't already peaked
because the world needs change what's
more bp
ceo declared his 111 year old oil
company
will transition to an integrated energy
company
we intend to reimagine energy so that we
do so
for the good of the planet and in a way
that improves people's lives
it's a sign of the future increasing
investment in renewables such as solar
and wind by bp
and other major oil companies but to
conclude that oil and gas is going away
is fantasy says alberta's premier and we
know
that you cannot function a modern
industrial economy
any time now we're in the foreseeable
future without
massive consumption of oil and gas
indeed the post covet 19 economy will
need oil and gas
it's still cheaper than green says this
energy analyst
the lowest cost energy is what is what
the households of the world need
so the incumbent fuels of coal oil and
natural gas
will get the job done but even oil
companies are thinking beyond
oil norway's stat oil changed its brand
to equinor
petro canada is promoting itself as a
leader in electric vehicle charging
stations
alberta remains focused on producing oil
and offsetting the effects with programs
like carbon capture
alberta thinks it will be able to
continue to compete
in a global oil market that that's seen
declining demand over the long term
it's really risky especially when we
have other options that are at our
fingertips
canada is a country that's been built on
resource extraction
and the reality is if we're going to
address climate change we have to change
that model
it's not clear whether oil consumption
will speed up or slow down
after the pandemic bp for one isn't
waiting to find out
a tenfold increase in low carbon
investment
eric sorensen global news toronto
montreal-based bombardier has sold off
its train division to a european company
for hundreds of millions of dollars less
than it hoped
the deal is valued at 8.4 billion
dollars u.s
bombardier will only get 4 billion from
alstom because the french train giant is
assuming much of the division's debt
the sale works out to about 350 million
dollars less than what the two sides had
agreed upon in february
bombardier still has more than 9 billion
dollars in debt
for decades bombardier has received
billions of dollars in federal and
provincial subsidies
and loan guarantees u.s lawmakers blame
what they call a culture of concealment
at boeing
and flawed regulation for those two
crashes involving the 737 max 8 jet
a congressional committee report
released today chastised the jet
manufacturer
and the u.s federal aviation
administration the democratic chair of
the committee says boeing and the faa
gambled with public safety in the
critical time period between the two
crashes
the first a lion air flight went down
off indonesia in october 2018
less than five months later an ethiopian
airlines flight crashed after takeoff
346 people were killed in the two
crashes
an 18-month long investigation
determined boeing failed in its design
and development of the max
and the faa failed in its oversight of
boeing and its certification of the
aircraft
it also scrutinized the close ties
between the company and the regulator
the global fleet of max eights has been
grounded since march of 2019 and boeing
is still working
to recertify those jets global news has
learned justin burke the man convicted
of killing police officers in new
brunswick in 2014
is in the hospital after a drug overdose
multiple sources have told global news
that burke overdosed last week at the
atlantic institution in
new brunswick correctional service
canada would not comment on the matter
citing privacy concerns burke killed
three rcmp
officers and injured two others he was
taken into custody after a nearly
30-hour manhunt
and he is serving a life sentence
hurricane sally slams into the
southeastern u.s
coming up the path of destruction and
what is still to come
hurricane sally made landfall early this
morning in alabama and along the florida
panhandle and the damage
is devastating punishing winds and heavy
rain brought down trees and led to
catastrophic flooding
many homes and businesses are swamped
sally has now been downgraded to a
tropical storm but it's just one of four
ominous weather systems
churning in the atlantic right now as
jackson protzko reports officials are
warning
thousands may be in the path of rising
water in the days to come
a slow-motion disaster arrived along the
gulf coast
hurricane sally is a roaring storm
moving at a snail's pace
delivering unprecedented amounts of rain
as it slowly moves inland at
walking speed while winds whip
at everything in its path we had strong
winds for a long period of time
instead of just for a few hours it was
for 12 hours
in parts of alabama and the florida
panhandle there's extensive damage to
buildings
a huge section of a bridge leading out
of pensacola collapsed after being
struck by a construction barge
in alabama this marina was decimated and
dozens of boats sank
they're just beginning to tally up the
damage we're going to try to survive
this we're going to try going through
this and we're just going to be
trying to be safe but the real story is
the catastrophic
rainfall nearly a meter in some areas
downtown pensacola is under water
and flooding is expected to spread
across several states over the coming
days
catastrophic and life-threatening flash
flooding is ongoing right now with sally
along the florida and alabama coast
sally is part of an unusually active
hurricane season
with four named storms churning in the
atlantic at the same time
one more storm and forecasters will run
out of names
they'll have to use the greek alphabet
right now we are in the peak of
hurricane season
for the atlantic and typically it ends
around november 15th or november 30th
there's no reason to expect the rest of
hurricane season to be any quieter
with an ample supply of warm ocean water
on hand
leaving residents up and down the coast
to watch the forecast
while they pick up the pieces jackson
proskow global news
washington improving weather conditions
in the pacific northwest are raising
hopes of possibly getting the upper hand
on those wildfires
in washington state and parts of oregon
but winds inland are picking up in
central oregon where fires are reaching
areas untouched by flames for decades
the lakeside tourist city of detroit
oregon has lost nearly all
its businesses and public buildings
including city hall
officials are warning the area is still
extremely dangerous and residents should
not
return home
and there's no relief in sight in
california gusting winds and low
humidity are fueling more unpredictable
fires that have already burned more than
a million hectares since august 15th
fire crews have managed to save the
historic mount wilson observatory near
los angeles
the bobcat fire came within 150 meters
of the facility last night
the observatory is where astronomers
confirmed galaxies
exist outside the milky way
still ahead how to avoid a season of
sickness what happens when a pandemic
mixes with the flu
kovid 19 is top of mind for many
canadians right now and health experts
are warning about what's to come this
fall and winter
flu season is just weeks away under
normal circumstances seasonal sickness
tends to push
hospitals to the brink add the impact of
the pandemic
and there's concern about dueling flu
and coronavirus outbreaks
heather urex west looks at what's being
done to prepare for it
it arrives every year not long after
kids returned to class
the flu on top of covid19
grandmother brenda roland admits she's a
little worried about the months ahead
i am concerned and we've had the flu
shots in the past
and i think we're going to do it again
this year two seasons for me is uh
certainly a concern so even without
coving food's always a concern at this
time of the year
because we know that you see an epidemic
of cases and it can often strain the
hospital
because of people requiring both
hospitalization on the ward and
icu beds it's why this year the flu
vaccine may be more
important than ever and research out of
the university of british columbia
suggests demand will be
high after surveying 3 000 families
across
six countries 54 percent said they plan
to get the flu shot
up 16 percentage points from the year
before
that's prompted the public health agency
of canada to order more vaccine
13 million doses for the season compared
to 11.2 million
last year i think i'm doing it this year
because just be safe than sorry
the symptoms for both illnesses are the
same but while covid19
is usually mild for children the flu can
hit
very young kids hard and so far doctors
don't know what happens if children get
sick with both viruses
at the same time we don't have data to
speak to it
but i would presume and assume and worry
unfortunately
that children are co-infected by both
covid19 and influenza
likely will have a worse outcome than
children infected by
either them individually the flu is also
particularly dangerous for seniors
provinces are still working out how best
to distribute this year's vaccine
alberta and ontario plan to distribute
the high-dose formula
to long-term care residents who were at
the highest risk
but the vaccine won't be available in
canada for another month
and with covet 19 cases on the rise it's
difficult to know what the situation
across the country will be
once flu season finally arrives heather
urex west global news
calgary freedom with love up next a
couple's whirlwind fight for justice
this next story is a bit of an antidote
to all the bad news these days
it's about a professional athlete a
basketball star who put her career on
hold to embark on a journey for justice
maya moore took up the case of a man she
believed was wrongfully convicted
and as robin gill reports her journey
turned into a love story
i'm maya moore and i'm jonathan irons
for 13 years maya moore and jonathan
irons have been considered a team
well now they've put a ring on it we got
married a couple months ago and
we're we're excited to uh to just
continue this new chapter of life
together on abc's good morning america
the couple announced they tied the knot
two months ago a few years ago you know
we
acknowledged both acknowledged that we
had really strong feelings for each
other so much so that
you know i i wanted to marry her but at
the same time protect her because
being in a relationship with a man in
prison is
extremely difficult and painful moore
first developed a friendship with irons
when she was 18.
they met through a prison ministry he
was serving a 50-year sentence for
assault and burglary
moore who went on to have a career in
the women's nba began
advocating for changes to policing and
the legal system
in 2019 she decided to take a leave of
absence from the wnba
to help irons be vacated a year later
a judge overturned his conviction citing
a fingerprint at the crime scene that
was never produced as evidence
it could have saved him the 23 years he
spent in jail
[Applause]
i feel like i can live life now man i'm
free
moore hasn't played ball in almost two
years and she isn't in a rush to go back
to the court
right now i am trying to really just
breathe from this
long long battle her fight for social
justice isn't over
but for now it's time to reflect on a
story about liberty
and love robin gill global news
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is a bird's eye view of the
sunset over surrey bc
we'd love to see your canada please
email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching i hope to see you
here again tomorrow take care of
yourselves
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bye-bye